all right Ryan brands that you trust is
it coke or is it Pepsi RC Royal Crown I
I worked that dumb question Josh next
dumb question you're such a hipster
Sam's Cola you have a 14 ounce bottle of
RC so I I worked at americano in
Middletown Ohio when I was 13
yeah it because you're allowed to work
at 13 back then apparently and there's
that summer I was turning 14 so it was
right before high school and we had like
the generic version of everything right
it was just like it was the generic
version of Six Flags or Kings I wonder
well yeah what Americana was the place
looks like right now dude yeah there are
videos on YouTube right now of Americana
it's also called you all want to look it
up Lasorda Ville Lake is what they've
rebranded as for like two years but it
closed and I think Oh two or 99 it's
it's a ghost town year yeah they sold
awful like the roller coasters and stuff
so it's maybe maybe because we have at
least a certain a little bit of clout we
can throw around the Netflix name from
our last documentary maybe they let us
in there to film some stuff maybe he
dude it's like it's so sad and nostalgic
because I remember like but that's the
danger of nostalgia like I don't get any
value from the place but of course I've
been on YouTube looking at old videos i
derailed you from the generic brand of
everything yeah why they were like they
were like sponsored by RC there's no
wonder Lee I'm not I mean they chose
Americana to sponsor right here so
here's the thing
and I think they own 7up I assume they
still do that that was like their big
thing yeah yeah a 7 oz resting so here's
the my point in bringing up the whole
coke pepsi 7up thing it's like just
because it's a brand doesn't make it a
good thing those are all terrible things
those are just sugar those things are
bad for you and so a brand does
make it trustworthy or good it just
makes it a brand yeah I mean if here's
what Leslie I would say go listen to
episode number 56 yeah that is where
Josh and I do talk about some brands
it's specific to clothing right but
again those are preferences example
brand is not going to a brand itself is
it gonna make you better or worse right
um it is just a brand but what's funny
is like the the way I and maybe I
interpreted the question wrong Josh you
tell me but the way I interpret the
question was is how can I buy more
responsibly what what what brands are
more responsible for the environment
okay what brands are more responsible if
you want to have more if you want to be
more responsible to the environment
consume less yes there is not a brand
that is going to save the environment
right there is in fact there are there
are brands of Lake uh / brand - right
like there are brands like the against
malaria foundation is a technically a
sure and sure I guess I'm talking about
when it comes to more goods
yeah consumer goods when it comes to a
brand with consumer goods but there are
there are brands like with paper plates
and bowls like there's this new thing
where it talks about this is a net
positive for landfills when you bury
this bowl with other garbage and
actually helps the other garbage
decompose faster with that logic we
should be we should be air dropping
these paper poles all the landfills and
all over the world this is our healthy
decomposing one landfills they're gone
now right there isn't even a landfill
just wrap up all your trash into this
paper plate and they did disappear now I
think to a certain extent I'm not trying
to I'm not trying to like this any
brands that do that because I think to a
certain extent they probably do have a
point and there's science to back up how
it will help other things decompose but
ultimately if you want to be responsible
to the environment switch to one car my
less buy less things go ahead and it's
certainly better than then you're
putting plastic in a landfill so so the
question is can we be more responsible
with the things that we that we purchase
yes and I think it would it comes down
to
those individual things right yeah not
necessarily a brand yeah perfect and
when I think of brands that I don't
support it usually gets into a political
realm and well that's that's just
divisive so I'm not going to talk about
that here on the podcast right but my
point is is that when I consider brands
it's you usually doesn't have to do with
you know what's gonna have a better
impact on the environment because when I
think about brands like you know like a
PC versus a Mac they're both pretty
crappy for the environment yeah so what
I do is I'll buy a computer cuz we you
know I need a computer right and then I
hold on to it for the absolute longest
time I can hold on to it right and when
I can replace it I'll replace it so I
mean my point is is that there are
things that no matter no matter what
which brand you buy that company may not
be the most responsible company on the
on the planet don't leave it don't leave
it to the company to be responsible with
your consumer purchases leave it up to
yourself that's a pity put that in there
yeah well I mean I think about brands I
think about this essay from our friend
Colin right and he wrote this essay a
while ago from 2012 it has an update in
2017 and it's called loyalty or
happiness it goes a little something
like this brand loyalty demands that you
keep buying products from a specific
company no matter what you like the
brand so why wouldn't you support their
efforts think about that for a moment
brand loyalty means that even if another
brand has a superior product you'll
continue to buy the inferior one in fact
it generally means you won't even
acknowledge the other products
superiority or existence in the first
place you'll spend your money where
you've spent it before because that's
where you've spent it in the past that's
a bad reason to buy something from a
brand well I bought it before so I'm
gonna buy it again now don't get me
wrong
past performance can be indicative of
potential future performance but it's
not always indicative of future
performance dude there
craftsman is a great example of that
like like I'm not a tool guy craftsman
is a brand a brand of tools
yeah I'm not tool guy but this is a
brand of tools that back in the 80s
early 90s people went nuts for yeah it
was this very you know not only was an
american-made but it was this very very
reliable good quality product and so I
know tool guys who when they had to you
know in the early 2000s they'd replace
their craftsman stuff or buy new tools
wood for whatever job they needed and
they just bought craftsman because of
the brand loyalty right well craftsman
they know that they had their loyalty so
what craftsmen did at a certain point is
they now things are not all built in
America and the quality has gone way way
down because they don't have to rely on
the quality of the quality of their
product because they've done such a good
job I've been doctoring people with
their brand that can sit on the name yes
and Apple can do that right now
and thankfully they still make
relatively good widgets but there will
be a time where it's like I've heard Joe
Rogan talking about the terrible
keyboards on Apple recently he's like
you know when I write I want to be able
to feel the keys and and like I can't
feel it so I he's moved over to a
Windows computer for his writing just
because the the key and to me that is
like avoiding the brand loyalty but but
embracing the brands that make the best
thing right now
so the craftsman is one example or Ford
versus Toyota or Chevy versus was
probably better example like Chevy's
were the best car and the 70s and then
in the 80s and then all of a sudden the
90s came along and it was like what
happened this piece of junk is falling
apart on the lot and the sad part is is
like you still have people in the 90s no
it's still the best because there's
still caught up in the brand and then
eventually people realize like well no
this Toyota started driving and you and
I both drive Toyota's now right it would
be wrong of us to say I'm going to drive
Toyota's for the rest of my life yeah no
because if Toyota starts making a crappy
product I don't want to have brand
loyalty to it that it just means making
a bad decision that's what brand
ultimately is so I'll read a little bit
more of this and they'll put a link to
this essay in the show notes as well
this is why most companies dream about
winning the loyalty of their customers
they needn't compete quite so hard with
their rivals when they know you'll buy
regardless of how their product measures
up loyalty
we'll often consider to be a highly
desirable trait results in our ignoring
better opportunities in favor of the
ones that are more familiar instead of
taking the road that's most favorable
for us personally loyalty instructs us
to take the one that's most favorable
for the company we're currently we
currently work for instead of being the
person we want to be with instead of
being with the person we want to be with
loyalty compels us to stick with the
person we once wanted to be with because
they got there first that's the way to
think about this is just because someone
got there first so I could talk about a
few brands that I currently get value
from the pants I'm wearing our mission
workshop the shirt I'm wearing is a
mission workshop most of their stuff is
made in America or Canada or some other
place where you know there is not going
to be any kind of child labor labor or
unfair wage practices as a result you
tend to pay more but and just because
you're paying more for something doesn't
mean better quality either in this case
you're paying more and you're getting
good quality however if Mission workshop
next week next month next year a decade
from now produce worst quality I
personally would find it less appealing
yeah now just because mission workshop
works for me and the size of my body I'm
six 245 pounds
these same clothes aren't going to work
well for you necessarily right now you
own a pair of mission workshop pants or
different kind of pants our bigger
version of pants that I would wear and
so you find value in them as well but
not necessarily we both were different
brands of t-shirts not because of well I
have brand loyalty to one place you know
that you like now this one works better
for me some other brands that work well
for me you and I
sherry Doxie scanner right yeah so a
photo scanner like that is a brand that
has worked well for us we did something
called a scanning party Sean have you
put a link to the the scanning party
it's an essay that we wrote in the show
notes about scanning the excess stuff I
just did a living room conversation
about what to do with old DVDs and old
VHS tapes and old photos and old
yearbooks I did a living room
conversation in YouTube about that and
one of the the answers is if you have a
Doxie scanner or there are other
services you can use to scan these
things our website is hosted by Bluehost
that is a hosting company that we use
that I feel really good about their
other just fine hosts out there and
there are other free ways to do a blog
as well you can get on tumblr and start
a blog today blogspot I'm sure is still
a thing you could get out there and do
it doesn't have to be barriers out there
and so it's something that we've used
but there are other alternatives just
because it's something that you and I
use doesn't mean it's the best thing
that it's the thing that's best for you
yeah I'm trying to think if there are
any brands that I completely avoid
because of the way that they treat the
environment or or anything there's not
really again it goes the political stuff
like out for like certain well actually
like one of them is it's a fast-food
restaurant but I never eat there anyway
it would be the last food restaurant
every day it's like I avoid the thing I
already avoided I avoid that crack deal
are there any brands that you avoid that
that youth that are irresponsible with
whether it's the environment or whether
it's yeah any anything that's fast
anything that is fast fashion I avoid
for two reasons one is we throw away 88
pounds of clothes a year so if I really
wanted a shirt from H&M I'm sure I could
find plenty of use shirts if for some
reason I wanted or slashed one in the
dumpster they could repair that's the
other problem is they're a platinum no
hmm does that specifically but there are
other companies who will they there's 52
seasons a year for Bex and I were
walking past one of these fast fast fast
fashion stores the other day
and she goes it's amazing every time we
walk by the store the entire inventory
of the store is different
we've never been inside it but every
time we walk past like the entire
inventory he's changed out once a week
and what do they do with the old clothes
they just cut them up right off anyway
yeah and crazy in itself and so so we
can't give them away because that's not
it right off right but if we slashed
them yeah they're home in a dumpster
right then that's a write-off yeah and
then we go it's spit on homeless people
afterward right that's what it feels
like yeah
so here's here's what I think about I
think about what you said early on
consuming less so so I I consume
probably 90% less from what I did in my
20s maybe even more than 90% let's just
call it 90% yeah by consuming 90% less
and focusing on companies that that I
find value in but also I know they are
not killing puppies yes they're not
killing puppies and I can I can say all
right even if I if I support a company
like Apple who may have may or may not
have questionable practices in the the
building of their phones right you look
at Foxconn and the documentaries that
have been done yeah Foxconn and when I
when I look at that it's I'm also not
going out and buying a new Apple phone
every single year I mean back in our
corporate days I mean you and I would go
through three or four phones a year
probably dude you know for that
sometimes one a month yeah because we
had access to them right and so like I
would just consume consume consume so by
radically reducing our consumption the
brands matter less I'm just saying they
don't matter but I'm saying they matter
less because we're the best way to
affect change is to consume less and
ultimately that leads to having a better
life because you're usually when you
consume less you're creating yeah as
well well dude the the the American
people specifically are marketed to the
most out of any other people in the
world and we
have our consumption habits as a nation
you you know on an average you and I
probably fall below the average of
consumption definitely fall way of all
the average but but my point is is that
you know listening to two yokels talk
about consuming less it might sound
crazy because of the habits that we have
got into as a nation but but you know
with with this American freedom we have
it comes as great responsibility for us
to consume responsibly yeah
it doesn't mean don't consume that
that's not the message we want to put
out that course it means that yes we all
need to consume some stuff and that
stuff is going to make our life better
consuming better meals you know when I
had dr. Tommy wood on the podcast we
were talking about like if you if you
have a cheat meal what he's like he's
like you know what everyone smile I'll
eat a piece of cake but it better be a
good piece of cake as opposed to when
you and I were like fat kids it was just
like well what's the hostess cake I'll
grab from the shelf and eat it was
garbage man I don't know why but that
just made me really want pizza cuz
haven't had pizza in so long especially
with pineapple I [ __ ] love pond one
like you probably we just lost half our
audience yeah because I like pineapple
on pizza but you probably don't want
Little Caesars you're not craving Little
Caesars oh like if you were to go have a
piece of pizza right now you know I'm
gonna run Little Caesars real quick get
to five four five special or whatever
the hell it is you're completing fast
food places but yeah with you but it's
all the same yes
you put Arby's and and though season a
blender and I handed you both in a cup
the layouts the same thing literally the
same thing blend it up yeah so um what
other brands I like these are some
marrow the brand is strong I'm a big fan
of Jesus and marrow but they just left
compla or not yeah they're on no they're
on vice land they're going the Showtime
it's like my favorite TV show but their
tagline is the brand is strong just
finish out this this essay with with
Colin before we dive into the lightning
round here
he says instead of focus on loyalty I
would suggest we approach both our
product purchases and our relationships
analytically if we take the time to
figure out what we want and what is best
for us based on those once the company's
selling to us may just realize they're
selling to the wrong demographic or
making the wrong product and the people
were with may realize that we're not
ideal for them either this is not to say
that we should all be opportunists
moving from one shiny new thing to the
next shiny new thing regardless of the
company or person in question but it
does mean that if properly thought
through a change in direction is not an
ignoble act in fact such a shift could
be the most beneficial thing for
everyone involved and here's a little
update here at the end want to make a
lot of people feel uncomfortable
question the value of loyalty in their
presence the this nobility of loyalty is
so ingrained in most cultures that the
very idea that it might not be a good
thing can spark righteous anger or holy
terror and some I see that of some
people who have brand loyalty where it's
like of course this is the best thing oh
yeah and whether that is a Toyota
evangelist a Tesla evangelist and Apple
evangelist I'm not gonna evangelize for
any product or service I can tell you
what I get value from when I talk about
mission work shop or someplace like that
but I also I'm not going to say well I
stand behind this company no matter what
yeah well I think people too like they
have preferences and they are their
preferences that they really really
enjoy yes so when someone else prefers
something different it makes a kick it
can potentially make one feel less oh
that person doesn't prefer what I prefer
but I really prefer this and here's why
let me tell you why I prefer you need to
prefer this to yeah as opposed to
questioning why do I prefer that's the
thing Colin said here is he said take
time to figure out what you really want
and then you find the brands that will
serve that
recently on on the website we put out
that the the comparison the list of
essential items non-essential items and
junk we all know what the essentials are
we need to figure out the non-essential
are those are things that we want the
things that truly add value to our lives
the problem where we really get caught
up as we mistake all this extra junk
other people's preferences other
people's added values we say oh but
that's going to add value to my life too
you